Joe Pesci is one of the all-time greats
and versatile character actors he played
Jake LaMotta brother and manager and
Raging Bull a psychopathic Tommy DeVito
in Goodfellas and have legendary roles
in home alone my cousin Vinnie and the
Lethal Weapon franchise Pesci was a
welcome presence on the big screen for
decades who could successfully handle
high drama and humor funny how I mean
funny like I'm a clown a zoo but lately
we haven't heard much from the Oscar
winner while his talents have been
sorely missed here are some of the
reasons Joe Pesci's been off the radar
in recent years early retirements in
1999 when his acting career was still
very much alive
Pesci announced it largely retire from
the base in order to pursue his first
love music now while the lots of actors
decide to record an album or take a role
in a Broadway musical just because they
can Pesci actually has some chops in the
60s he was the guitarist for the band
Joey D and the starlighter's a position
he vacated to a slightly better
guitarist named Jimi Hendrix in 1968 he
released an album called Little Joe sure
can sing under the stage name of Joe
Richie he even introduced the two
musicians who'd go on to form the Four
Seasons but then his acting career took
off and music went on the back burner
for 30 years Pesci's retirement came
after the release of a bizarre LP called
Vincent LaGuardia Gambini scenes just
for you something of a novelty project
the title is derived from the name of
Pesci's my cousin Vinnie character
guests that hold be a good lawyer thing
didn't work out for Vinnie huh just for
friends every once in a while Pesci pops
out of retirement for an acting gig here
and there but there's usually a good
reason for it
for example Pesci is still very close
friends with Robert De Niro over the
course of four decades they've starred
in a number of movies together among
which are the best of both actors
stories careers like Raging Bull Casino
and Goodfellas the latter of which
netted Pesci the Academy Award for Best
Supporting Actor and what may be the
shortest Oscar acceptance speech in
history was my privilege thank you
it's his bond with De Niro that led to
Pesci's only major role of note since
2000 a cameo in The Good Shepherd the
2006
movie that was also Robert De Niro's
directorial debut other than that
Pesci she's only been seen in the 2010
brothel drama love ranch which combines
both boxing and the gambling scenes for
which she's framed and a 2011 Snickers
commercial in which he played himself
losing interest now that we know that
he's semi-retired and only comes out of
hiding for a role once in a while let's
talk about why a glance at his resume
reveals very few movies after the
classic casino was released in 1995 and
what he was being offered really
couldn't compete with his best films
remember eight heads in a duffel bag or
gun fishing Pesci's last major role was
the 1998 sequel Lethal Weapon 4 which
earned him a Razzie Award nomination for
worst Supporting Actor for reprising his
role as the obnoxious informant Leo gets
those movies and his subsequent walk
from Hollywood reflects a comment Pesci
made to the New York Times in 1992 I
love to star in movies but I want to
have good roles it doesn't help to get
starring roles in something that's no
good I mean that will just kill you
besides how could any subsequent role
possibly compete of what he's already
done
[Music]
gains and losses even after Pesci
retired he was still willing to take on
a big role if all the factors align
around 2011 he was set for a major
supporting role in a film about the
Gambino crime family with John Travolta
attached to star is John Gotti and Pesci
set to portray got his friends and
personal enforcer Angelo Ruggiero
Ruggiero was a big guy so Pesci
dutifully gained 30 pounds for the role
then he was reportedly dropped into a
smaller part and to offer to reduce
salary surely he must have had some
choice words for the execs who came to
him of that personally every [ __ ]
wiseguys go around
I'll take a piece of Pesci ultimately
committed his ire to paper and filed
suit against a production company ending
in an undisclosed settlement in 2013 and
the Gambino movie still hasn't been
filmed with or without Pesci but that
wasn't the only legal entanglement he's
found himself in the ex-wife the Hitman
and the attorney Pesci was married to
model actress Claudia Haro from 1988 to
1992 with whom he had a daughter
they must have remained on good terms
because harrows acting career started
after the divorce and of the five movie
she appeared in four were Pesci films
Pesci also stood by her side drawing a
very bizarre legal matter after her
split from Pesci Haro married Hollywood
stuntman Garrett Warren but things
soured in 1999 and about a year later
Warren was shot by a stranger at the
front door of his home in Westlake
Village California it took years to
figure out who shot him
but some evidence uncovered in a trunk
of a car in a drug bust directions to
Warren's house and his photograph set
police often running and they eventually
figured out that harrow had paid the
assailant a hitman to kill her
ex-husband she later hired another
hitman to finish the job
during her 2012 trial during which she
was free and 1.25 million dollar bail
Paro brought a huge entourage to the
courtroom each day including an urn
dressed in all white and her other
ex-husband Joe Pesci dressed all in
black
harro pled no contest and was sentenced
to just over 12 years in prison while
that's a preliminary hearing a witness
strongly implied the
she had paid for horrors hits against a
warrant police interviewed him and
searched his property and found them
absolutely unrelated to the crime time
for our comeback legal lunacy aside
there's always a chance Pesci my tree
emerge in the summer of 2016 he made a
surprise appearance at Spike TV's guys
Choice Awards alongside De Niro to
induct to Goodfellas into the guy movie
Hall of Fame De Niro mentioned a long
gestating movie called the Irishman
Scorsese had been trying to get off the
ground for years but remained stalled in
part because he wanted it to star not
just an arrow but the elusive Pesci
that's if Joe has any any more left in
him so so far all he keeps saying is go
yourself finally in early 2017 Netflix
paid a hundred and five million dollars
for the global rights to the film and
it'll supposedly be available in 2019
could this be the start of Pesci's
return well maybe it's up to me just a
little bit just a little bit insulting
it's okay though I'm used to it thanks
for watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]